today we take a crucial step on the road
out of the crisis
i am very happy to present to european
leaders our recovery package called
next generation eu this proposal is
ambitious
and it is balanced together with the new
mff
this is a huge stimulus of 1
850 billion euros
and it does not only help the economies
of the countries which were hit hardest
by the virus
it also helps the countries whose
economies
have been hit hard indirectly because of
the lockdowns
europe must now invest and reform to get
out of the crisis
a next generation eu is designed to help
europe's recovery
be resilient sustainable and digital
in other words it will help europe to
modernize
this is a chance europe cannot afford to
miss
i want a europe which is better able to
weather global storms
and provide a safe home for future
generations
so i'm looking forward to today's
discussion
i'm convinced that for common success we
must stay focused on the big picture
we must all pull together we cannot
afford any delay